Everyone in their dog is moving to the cloud.
So you'd expect there to be a lot of questions on the exam.
So you'd expect there to be a lot of questions on the exam related to cloud computing.
Because there's one or two security issues involved with moving to the cloud.
And while there will be some questions on the exam related to cloud, there's not a huge amount of them.
And in fact, there's only this one small section in this entire giant course that we're going to talk about cloud computing.
And the reason for that is this.
ISC squared, the organization behind this CISSP exam, made a decision a few years ago.
They were seeing where the industry was going.
They were seeing that everyone was starting to move to the cloud.
And so they had a decision to make.
When they were updating the CISSP exam material, they could start to build in more and more and more cloud material.
Or they could break it out as an entirely different certification.
And that's exactly what they did.
They broke it out into a separate certification, which is the CCSP Certified Cloud Security Professional.
Another one of those courses that we teach.
Another course that we teach.
And the reason that they chose to do this.
And I think it was a good decision, not just that they were trying to make more money on certifications.
There's a lot of intricacies in cloud.
There's a lot of fundamental concepts that you need to understand.
And there's a lot in the governance, the processes, the technicalities of how to properly move to the cloud.
Secure the cloud, know how to have interoperability, portability, be able to remember, have a reversibility, get out of the cloud.
There's a lot of complication here.
And it's more than would reasonably fit in this course.
And so I think it made a lot of sense for them to move that into a separate certification.
And so in this course, the CISSP, I'm going to cover cloud at like the 10,000 or 30,000 foot level.
Very high level, just some of the very basics.
Because you will get a few questions, but not a huge amount of them.
And if you really want to get deep into the cloud computing, go and take something like the CCSP.
So let's get into some of the basics of the cloud.
And let me start by asking you this simple question.
What is the cloud?
Think about this from above.
Trying to find it in very simple, easy to understand terms.
How would you explain it to someone who has never understood the cloud or never thought of it before?
It's actually a bit of a trick question.
It's very difficult to describe what is cloud in very simple terms.
And the reason is this, cloud is many, many different things to many different people.
It can be systems running in your own data center.
It can be systems running in another service provider's data center.
It can be everything from, you know, creating an entire virtual data center
to just doing identity access management or security as a service or database as a service.
There is so many things that fall under the umbrella of cloud.
What the industry has settled on is rather than trying to come up with a nice, simple, concise definition of cloud, which is impossible.
Instead, what we use is a set of defining characteristics.
There's five primary and a sixth kind of characteristic.
That if a service complies with these characteristics, then you can call it cloud.
So let's spend a few minutes going through those characteristics.
And it starts to help explain a little bit of what cloud actually is.
The first characteristic is on-demand self-service.
And this is the idea that if you are using cloud, you can request cloud services by yourself.
And you can do it whenever you want.
Nowadays, what does it actually take to request cloud services?
Well, for free stuff, you can just sign up for free.
Things like Gmail and box and all these sorts of things.
These are big cloud services that you need nothing more than maybe an email address to sign up for.
And even the paid services, all you really need is a credit card number.
And this is a really important defining characteristic of cloud.
Because a lot of organizations nowadays, they want to fail fast.
They want to innovate. They want to rapidly try things out.
And that's very difficult to do in a traditional environment where,
if a lot of my clients, I ask them, how long does it take you to get a new server provision in your environment?
And it's not uncommon for someone to say weeks, maybe even months, two, three months, to get a new server provisioned.
If you're trying to rapidly innovate, fail fast.
It's pretty hard to do that if you're waiting two or three months just for a server to be set up.
And so one of the really, really valuable things of cloud on-demand self-service,
you can sign up for an unbelievable amount of services, terabytes of storage,
machine learning algorithms, vision APIs, all sorts of crazy stuff.
And all you need is clicking a couple of those buttons.
And it all happens instantaneously or nearly so.
Lost my pointer. There we go.
So that's the first characteristic of cloud.
The next one is what is known as broad network access.
And what this characteristic is about is from where and what type of devices can you access the cloud.
Most cloud services are web-based applications.
And most cloud is public cloud or software as a service in the public cloud.
Which means that the vast majority of the way that we access the cloud is through a web browser across the internet.
And everything has a web browser installed in it nowadays.
I was at Home Depot recently and I was browsing the internet on a fridge.
So on-demand self-service means you can essentially access most of these cloud services from anywhere in the world.
Because most cloud services are accessed through a web browser.
Now the next characteristic resource pooling.
This is where we need to spend a few minutes on this one.
This one is really critical.
There are three primary resources that we pool share in the cloud.
Compute network and storage.
And when we say we pool or we share these resources, what we're saying is that as a customer in the cloud,
you can get access to compute computers, you know, like a CPU essentially.
It allows you to do problem solving.
You can get access to network.
The ability to move bits around between your different systems, databases, and so forth.
And storage, which allows you to store the bits.
In the cloud, you can get access to all three of these resources.
But very importantly, your access to all of these resources is virtualized.
You do not have direct physical access to a hard drive to a CPU to the network.
Your access to all of these services is virtualized.
There's a layer of abstraction.
Which allows all of these resources to be shared across cloud customers.
What's the advantage of this?
Because there's a big one.
Let me ask you this.
In a traditional data center, if you were to look at an average server, like the payroll server,
what would the average utilization be of an average server in a well-run data center?
The answer is usually somewhere in the range to 10 to 20%.
So you take this very expensive piece of hardware, a server,
and you're only utilizing 10 to 20% of the resources on that server, on average.
It's a very inefficient use of that and very expensive hardware.
And any well-run data center is like this traditional data center.
Why?
Well, it's because you don't size a server based on average utilization.
You size a server based on peak utilization.
And so take the payroll server as an example.
The vast majority of this time, what's the payroll server doing?
Not much.
Once in a while someone might log in to like pay you less or something, but that's it.
But then once every two weeks or once a month, what's the payroll server do?
It runs the payroll batch job.
And then for that period of time, you know, your CPU usage, your RAM usage,
it's spiked, max utilization.
And then you go back to doing almost nothing.
So in a traditional data center, we're only getting, you know,
we're only using 10 to 20% of the capacity of our systems.
Very inefficient.
Now in the public and the cloud, especially the public cloud,
because access to resources virtualized, it allows us to share those resources.
So in the cloud, we don't have what's typically what's called a server.
You have a compute node.
A compute node is essentially a server.
It's a CPU and a SRAM on top of which you can run virtual machines.
And these virtual machines are accessing the compute resources of this compute node.
Now in the cloud, because you can share this compute node across multiple clients,
you can run multiple virtual machines simultaneously on top of a hypervisor,
which is on top of the compute node.
And so these multiple virtual machines can share the underlying hardware,
which allows you to put a whole bunch of different virtual machines,
virtual servers on top of one compute node, and get much better resource utilization
of that underlying hardware.
Because each of those virtual servers might only be running along at 10 to 20% capacity,
something like that.
But if you put enough of them onto a compute node,
the overall resource usage of the compute node,
the underlying physical hardware, what's that?
Well, in the cloud, it's not uncommon to achieve resource utilization of 70, 80,
maybe even 90% of the underlying hardware.
So traditional data sender, you're getting like 10 to 20% utilization of the hardware.
In the cloud, you might be achieving 70, 80% utilization of the underlying hardware.
So much more effective use of the underlying hardware,
because you can virtualize, share the access amongst customers.
And I'll add one other piece to this that really helps drive down the costs.
When you look at what the big cloud providers and how much hardware they buy,
it is astronomical.
They buy a huge number of hard drives of CPUs, of network devices.
And so as a result, the prices that they're paying for that hardware
is, you know, economies of scale much lower than a traditional company
could typically buy stuff for.
Like when you look at the Amazon, the Google's, the Facebook's,
the Azure Microsoft of the world, they buy hardware at staggering levels.
They're spending billions of dollars every year building out their data centers,
which means they get economies of scale that no one else can achieve.
And that makes the underlying costs of the compute network and storage
and the cloud much cheaper than what you can traditionally achieve
in a traditional data center.
But I'll caveat that with one very important thing.
And my experience working with a lot of companies that move to the cloud,
they're overall costs moving to the cloud have not actually been cheaper.
The underlying resources and compute network and storage are cheaper.
But when you layer on top of all the additional services that you need,
it can often end up being a lot more expensive.
That's a discussion for another course.
But that's resource pooling.
You share compute network and storage across multiple customers.
Now, next one, rapid elasticity and scalability.
What this means is that in the cloud, you can rapidly, quickly increase
your, your use of compute network and storage.
If you suddenly want hundreds of new virtual CPUs to run something on top of,
done. If you want a petabyte of storage, done.
If you want tons and more network bandwidth, done.
And this again is very different than traditional data center.
Let's say in a traditional data center, you're like,
you know what, I want a petabyte of storage.
So you call up EMC, takes them a month or two,
but they ship out a few trucks worth of hard drives and storage race servers.
And you spend another month setting all this stuff up.
And now you've got your petabyte of storage.
And then you're like, nah, you know what, I don't need any more.
Too bad, you bought it. It's yours now, right?
Whereas in the cloud, rapid elasticity means you can quickly increase
your utilization of any of the compute network and storage.
And just as rapidly decrease your utilization.
So rapid elasticity.
And care closely tied to this is what's known as measured service,
which is the cloud service provider carefully measures your usage of the cloud,
how much compute you're using, how much network, how much storage,
and you only pay for what you use.
And so if you're only using that petabyte of storage for 10 minutes,
you're only paying for that petabyte of storage for 10 minutes.
So those are the five defining characteristics of cloud.
And if you get any questions asking you what are the five defining characteristics,
that's them.
But there's sometimes a sixth characteristic that's put in there.
And it's known as multi-tenancy.
And the reason that's not always in the list is because it's not always true.
There's one major difference between public cloud and private cloud.
Public cloud is accessible usable by anyone.
So therefore it is multi-tenancy.
But private cloud is reserved only accessible by one consumer.
Therefore, not multi-tenancy.
The majority of cloud is public cloud.
So the majority of cloud is multi-tenancy.
But not all of it.
We'll talk about the different deployment models in the next video.
We'll talk about public, private, community, and hybrid cloud.
But that's why multi-tenancy doesn't apply everywhere.
Thank you very much.